[Música]
y una gran pregunta que me ha hecho
números sobre todo cuando me enteré más
de 350 presos políticos asesinados
políticos torturados exiliados y
secuestrados y entre otras cosas
[Música]
hacer convencer a esos militares y
generar tensión política atención a
ellos como ciudadanos venezolanos que
también tienen madres enfermas que
también tienen familiares que lo
necesitan también hay que atender a su
familia no solamente apelando a su
conciencia el respeto a la constitución
sino también un rol
[Música]
lo que pasa en un país de la región va a
pasar en todos porque porque venir
teherán en canadá también han visto
también la calidad de los venezolanos
han recibido una migración importante en
toronto que no está agua en quebec y en
algunas otras ciudades y tenemos un
potencial enorme no solamente para
ayudar a la región que nuestros recursos
sirvan como palanca de desarrollo pero
también por un valor fundamental que
ustedes como nosotros apreciamos la
libertad y la democracia esa es nuestra
lucha
[Música]